hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video mein name ist krankhaft
mister klartext ich bevorzuge letzteres
leute ich bin mal wieder über etwas
gestolpert ihr kennt mich ja die hat bei
mir schon ein auto gesehen was anwenden
fährt schon gesehen wie man schrift auf
wasser schwimmen lassen kann
oh oh mein gott es hat geklappt seht ihr
dass leute oh mein gott dass das schwebt
auf dem wasser was habt ihr noch gesehen
wie ein europäisches spritzt wenn jetzt
wasser raus kommt leute eh okay dann
heule ich halte dann spiele ich nicht
mehr mit ihr als obmann ich will dir
wird worauf heute habe ich mal wieder
etwas für euch am start was richtig
richtig cool werden könnte ich habe
nämlich immer so ein bisschen die augen
und ohren auf den street was es so einen
coolen verrückten sachen gibt und heute
habe ich das hier für euch hier steht
einfach nur black drauf aber ich habe
schwarze farbe für euch also wer jetzt
gerade keinen like dahl ist muss ganz
ehrlich sagen was los mit den leuten
last jetzt leichter nein es ist
natürlich etwas besonderes und zwar
handelt es sich hierbei das schwarze
schwarz der welt das heißt nämlich black
to point euro ich weiß nicht warum wir
einfach nur black draufsteht und ich
habe mir das aus uk also aus
großbritannien bestellt auf der
rückseite steht superflat super nett
oder auch supermacht segmente grillitsch
paint also superflache jana ist ein
bisschen die künstlerin ist flache farbe
gut für nicht gefährdet die dicke
schichten auftretendes gibt es aber die
flachen geschichten ok ja ansonsten
keine heißen oberflächen aus der welt
von kindern also steht eigentlich an
sich nur zeug drauf was man halt auch
farbe erwarten würde
dass man es nicht trinken soll und so
aber ich habe ein video gesehen und ich
würde sagen da können ja mal ganz kurz
reinschauen hier seht ihr auf der linken
seite in dem video eine statue und
rechts ist genau die gleiche statue bloß
wurde sie angemalt mit dieser farbe und
die sieht einfach aus als wärst du ein
schwarzes loch oder als wäre es
irgendwie in der nachbearbeitung rein
gemacht und genau diesen effekt wollen
wir heute auch mal testen ich klicke mal
so ein bisschen durch total krass oder
was hier übrigens an dieser stelle
machen solltet ihr solltet auf den kanal
krankhafter gehen und dann abonnieren
ich zeige euch mal was wir gekauft haben
zum testen wir haben darauf bin ich mega
gespannten im max die wir dann mal mit
der schwarzen farbe
ich hätte mir vor wenn das wirklich so
die kontur wegnimmt dann hat man einfach
so einen schwarzen punkt im gesichts
könnte richtig coole aus den tag dann
haben wir ein eichhörnchen was ihr auch
schwarz anmalen wollen sie haben einen
heften mit werbung aus dem laden gekauft
haben und wir haben einen pinsel den
wollen wir auch spaß einmal näher mit
dem womit oder entertainment besser
seite hier leute ab danke abonniert für
mehr entertainment danke sie damit
meinen wir die sachen einfach an wollen
wir loslegen lesen dass regen ok so
leute dann nehme ich jetzt dieses
magazin
ich bin jetzt auch das stimmt ja ist
jetzt mit dabei war jana ist ja
künstlerisch begabt und das muss man
halt auch sein und die massen an zumal
das natürlich mit ins boot geholt danke
bitte sehr gerne im ok wir nehmen jetzt
dieses buch bitte macht das zuhause ein
und legen es auf unserem tisch und mit
was von anfang an richtig macht
wir haben ich bin so gestand wollte ich
glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht dass das
funktioniert das ist seegras für bin ich
dann lösen sie auf jeden fall trocknen
lassen ja ich habe noch mehrere
geschichten und auch die stirn
schwer war das hast du so gut getroffen
oder ist susan dietrich okay dann leute
lassen wir mal ein bisschen farbe drauf
gehen wo wir haben so viel
und ja ich bin ich bitte dich du ja viel
wenn nein ich bin gespannt wenn man aber
trotzdem wird das nicht so schön weist 1
bisher welche keinen großen unterschied
dass es vor allem halt gerade glänzend
wenn es trocken ist das hoffentlich
macht also das wird nämlich viel
ausmachen
davor da steht ja auch einfach nur fleck
drauf der mann konnte mir einfach noch
geschickt
also auf jeden fall gut für ist das egal
deshalb ist auf jeden fall verspricht
also leute wir malen dass man fertig
[Musik]
okay leute wir haben einen film geholt
haben das ganze ein bisschen zu
beschleunigen
[Musik]
also es hat einfach sehr gute acrylfarbe
aber die stücke jetzt nicht diese dieses
ganze nicht unterrichten flexit leute
das ist jetzt alles angemalt und
irgendwie das ist einfach nur schwarz es
sieht einfach aus dokumentierte gute
grüne farbe aber wie man sehen kann sie
dann immer noch so hände reflexe und das
ist immer noch von dem licht und ist
dafür nicht so wie in dem video das
wieder frei
okay leute wir mitbekommen abläuft das
irgendwie nicht ganz so wie geplant man
erkennt halt noch relativ deutlich dass
es halt konturen gibt ich habe mich
gerade mal ein bisschen umgeschaut im
internet gehabt aber eine ganz lustige
geschichte gefunden die ich euch nicht
vorenthalten wollte vor diesem black
topalow welches übrigens in anderen
videos irgendwie blendend funktioniert
gab es schon mal einen schwarz welches
zu diesem zeitpunkt das schwärzeste
schwarz der welt war und zwar ist der
typ der das entworfen hat annika pur und
was der gemacht hat er hat sich das
sichern lassen so dass nur er das
verwenden durfte und der künstler dieses
schwarze entworfen hat das duo sample
heißt der steht auch hier drauf hat dann
halt black to porto entworfen welches
halt vergleichbar schwarz ist aber dass
jetzt total lustig ist dieser stuart
semple lässt sich bei jedem kauf von
black to punto bestätigen dass die
käufer nicht alles kaputt sind also
nicht derjenige der es nur für sich
selbst behalten wollte man muss
bestätigen dass man nicht der ist damit
man das kaufen kann und die fotos hier
sind alle total heftig also guckt mal
hier zum beispiel das sieht aber aus wie
photoshop und das ist halt von seinem
eigenen instagram also ich würde sagen
wir geben noch nicht auf sondern
probieren noch ein bisschen weiter in
einem anderen video was ich gesehen habe
wurde zum beispiel alufolie damit
angemalt und das war auch total heftig
aus
das war meine finger abgeschnitten
warten wir mal ab wer trotz
währenddessen in einem der videos die
ich gesehen habe wurde aber vor jahren
gemalt und das ist total heftig
ausprobieren wir das auch mal aus da war
so ein kreis in die mitte wo hab ich
doch dem material funktioniert ist wo
mein gott wie viele leute kommen ja erst
mein jahren ist finger an der kasse
da erkennt man noch die konturen seht
ihr dass leute dass sie die kraft aus
zudem wäre so das loch in der alufolie
siege ein echtes - ja das ist einfach
ein schwarzes loch
der alu folie ist schon heftig was wäre
so ein loch so ich hatte gerade die idee
dass es bestimmt klasse aussieht wenn
man nur eine lichtquelle von vorne
hatten habe ich es hinten mal das licht
ausgemacht ist sieht schon echt echt
heftig aus oder was meint ihr
solange ich hoffe dass jetzt einfach
nicht allzu viel um getrocknete farbe
dran ist einfach mal die maske auf
vielleicht sieht sie ein bisschen
krasser ausgleich währte staat seine
ganze gesicht ok also glaube ihr könnt
immer noch meine gesichtskonturen
erkennen oder sehe ich aus wie ein
gangster wie ein krimineller
ob sie davon gebrauch oder ok also ich
muss sagen an der maske ist es so krass
also auf jeden fall nicht so krass wie
im original video das eichhörnchen ist
schon heftig was man generell dazu sagen
muss es doch deutlich anders der
unterschied zwischen den augen und der
kamera also so erkennt man doch deutlich
mehr konturen und deutlich mehr schatten
als man halt auf der kamera erkennt
gerade wenn das halt so ein bisschen
entfernt ist aber am heftigsten muss ich
sagen sie auf der kamera echt dass
schwarz auf der adolf folie aus sieht
einfach aus wie so ein schwarzes loch
okay leute wir wollen noch ein bisschen
rum experimentieren wir mal noch einmal
eine kleine christbaumkugeln und ein
basketball an und
neben nicht und dann werden wir uns
gleich zurück ich habe jetzt noch mal
mit basketball angemalt und ich bin
gespannt wie es auf der kamera aussieht
das ist mal wieder so dass man doch ein
bisschen was erkennt somit dem echten
auge aber drehen jetzt einfach mal um
und in meiner kennt reflexion ja doch
man sieht schon dass es sehr sehr
schwarz ist da erkennt man doch durchaus
die reflexion ist es nicht so ein geiler
effekt wie in dem video was sie gefunden
habt und zuletzt die christbaumkugel
hier ist es da die sich berufen
okay da richtig heftig ist der effekt
hat wenn man ein bisschen weiter weg ist
ja okay so zum beispiel dann sieht es
schlecht aus diesem kleinen schwarzes
loch oder ok dass wir sind die sachen
die wir haben sieht alles schon cool aus
aber ihr seht auch hier jetzt wieder da
sind halt überall die reflexion und das
funktioniert leider nicht so gut wie in
dem video was ich gesehen hab aber muss
ja nicht immer alles klappen also ist
aber trotzdem interessant gewesen und
ich glaube dort allein für diesen alle
welt hier
das ist schon echt feierlich oder es ist
richtig krass dass ich kann mir durch
das portal ist das irgendwie dass das
schwarze schwarz der welt ist aber so
wie mit diesen beiden figuren ist halt
wirklich nicht und auf dem sofa und mir
ist aufgefallen dass sich scheinbar
keine abmoderation aufgenommen habe
deshalb in diesem sinne ich hoffe dass
wieder durchgefallen die sims vom
nächsten mal wieder und bis dahin
tschüss abonniert